hier la Cour de cassation a rendu une
décision plutôt inattendue refusée de
donner son code de déverrouillage de
portable peut désormais constituer un
délit lorsqu'ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir
commis un effet les individus seront
désormais tenus de livrer aux autorités
judiciaires le mot de passe de leur
téléphone pour qu'elle puisse
approfondir leur enquête et refuser de
divulguer le code de déverrouillage de
leur portable sera désormais puni et
pourrait avoir de lourdes conséquences
jusqu'à 3 ans de prison et 270 000 euros
d'amende
c'est ce qu'on a de plus privé il y a
quatre d'une enquête justement
c'est que ma meuf fera jamais partie de
la police
[Applaudissements]
non mais quand aujourd'hui c'est presque
plus intime qu'un domicile et un
policier entre dans un domicile il doit
avoir un mandat on entre pas dans un
téléphone comme ça on va toujours plus
loin dans l'espionnage dans la privation
des libertés moi ça me choque
tu peux pas dire d'un côté on marche sur
la tête la justice ne fonctionne pas et
quand on donne des armes à la justice de
dire ah bah non je veux pas je suis
désolé c'est dans le cadre d'une enquête
extrêmement précise ça doit être relié
au fait que ton téléphone ferme à
résoudre ce réseau de l'enquête genre
notamment il y a eu un trafiquant de
drogue qui part deux fois a refuser de
donner les codes de son téléphone ce qui
fait que par deux fois ils l'ont libéré
si on avait eu les codes du téléphone et
bien il aurait pu être emprisonné et
donc vous pouvez pas dire prenez son
contraire
je suis d'accord avec avec Guillaume
avec Manon va vraiment au plus profond
de l'intime des photos de famille des
machins
il y a toute sa vie dans un téléphone à
la police de trouver d'autres moyens
c'est pas avec un téléphone
vous sur votre start-up
vous avez toute votre vie c'est cool
non mais c'est ce qu'elle dit Guillaume
c'est comme notre maison en fait donc on
peut pas refuser
à la police
ceux qui disent oui sont complètement
absurdes et un conséquent et on est sûr
c'est le premier pas vers la violation
de l'intime faire que c'est fini si vous
acceptez ça c'est fini on va entrer chez
vous vous dites pour les besoins de
l'enquête mais c'est faux vous savez
très bien que ça va être étendu mais
vous encore une fois vous avez mal lu
les attendus j'en ai marre de débattre
avec quelqu'un qui a mal lu les attendus
arrêter
[Applaudissements]
même quand c'est pas évident
la Cour de cassation a mis des années à
trancher ça a été retoqué rotoqué à la
fin il y a des gens qui ont dit on y va
c'est le premier pas vers le fait de
tuer la liberté des gens
d'une enquête moi je suis d'accord
tu étais bien content d'aller voir dans
son téléphone
de pédophilie on parle pas d'enquête
comme ça banale là ils veulent faciliter
ça mais si heureusement qu'on
sur les réseaux sociaux pour voir c'est
les photos
pédophilie ça sera dans quel enquête
c'est pas du tout la même chose là on
est en train de tuer toutes les libertés
toutes les libertés exactement là je
suis d'accord avec Mathieu c'est pas
précis il se passe si c'est dans le
cadre du suspect de la personne
incriminée ou son entourage alors tout
pour être toujours justifié c'est c'est
voilà c'est la fin de la liberté on
empiète on empiète tous les goûts
jamais été rendu frotter ça
marche sur la tête etc quand on donne
des moyens vous n'êtes pas contents
faudrait savoir on dit que c'est long
on a dit ici que la justice allait était
lente que c'est trop long les affaires à
traiter et là vous on peut en fait vous
contredisez tout seul parce que vous
dites on rentre pas comme ça chez les
gens bien sûr on rentre chez les gens
quand il y a une enquête il rentre chez
toi
il fouille dans ta voiture il fouille
on parle dans le cadre bancaire dis-lui
que j'en sais par un procureur
on va pas dire dans l'arrêt de bus
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
calmez-vous tout ce que vous dites nul
tu rigolais franchement moi je suis
assez d'accord avec ça avance
alors moi je suis d'accord avec le nom
euh voilà voilà
parce que les gens pensent qu'on va leur
prendre leur téléphone à l'arrêter
une enquête au procureur fallait
réfléchir avant ne va pas devant un
procureur